Native American actor Nathan chasing
horse accused of sex trafficking and
sexually assaulting indigenous underage
girls faced a judge for the first time
this morning thank you for joining us at
four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian
Loftis Victoria Saha she was in court
shares what happened and what other
Indian reservations say about their
interactions with him
it was a much anticipated initial
appearance as we got to see Nathan
chasing horse for the first time since
his arrest and his family was right
there to support him
Nathan chasing horse walked into the
courtroom Thursday morning and
immediately made eye contact with his
family a man who identified himself as
chasing horses brother shaking a rattle
that was hanging on his neck
chasing horse often used a rattle in his
ceremonies his attorney Mike Wilfong
points out to the judge the support
chasing horse had in the courtroom
s
again that did speak with me
the former actor was arrested outside
his North Las Vegas home Tuesday night
after police and SWAT swarmed in police
say he let a cult known as the circle
persuading underage girls to believe
Spirits wanted them to have sex with him
documents say he also portrayed himself
as the medicine man and had at least six
wives but it's unclear if any of them
were in the courtroom chasing horse was
banned from the Fort Peck reservation in
Montana back in 2015 after allegations
of trafficking Angeline shiku grew up in
that reservation has memories of chasing
horse the people that were in chasing
horses Circle they would often threaten
the ones that weren't for him cheek says
as a young high school girl chasing
horse would often try to recruit some of
her classmates to be his wife a lot of
people were kind of scared how their
story at the time because there was a
lot of young women involved